in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion from May 18, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyrs,
Edochlius, Balinos, and Benedemus.
Edochlius, Balinos, and Benedemus were Christians from Athens who fearlessly preached the good
news and publicly exhorted the pagans to renounce their superstitions, arrested and taken before
the governor.
They were beaten, and after having suffered other tortures thrown into a burning furnace
in which they gloriously consummated their martyrdom.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.